every year on lindau island in Germany
dozens of Nobel laureates come to meet
with hundreds of young scientists
it's rare for so many laureates to
gather like this so I'm taking the
opportunity to ask some big questions
about the state of Medicine today to try
to get a picture of health
I suffer from hay fever but if I take
these it makes me drowsy drowsiness is
unpleasant but other side effects can be
much more dangerous the question is
could we ever develop drugs that have no
side effects no I would hope that we can
I don't think that drugs have side
effects in the last century there have
been incredible advances in drug
development from the ordinary aspirin to
cutting-edge combination therapies
transforming HIV treatments human health
is ruled by pharmaceuticals but almost
every drug has a fundamental limitation
whilst treating the core problem they
also produce side effects that can harm
the body in surprising ways sometimes
fatally but maybe all this could change
I met up with some young researchers who
one day may affect side effects so can
we ever develop drugs that don't have
any side effects I would hope that at
some point in the future we can move to
a point where we can create drugs that
have minimized side effects I'm not sure
if we'll ever be able to make drugs that
are completely side-effect free but I
would hope that we can what are the
challenges in creating drugs without
side effects well one of the first times
is that people are different so
different side effects
we found in different people and that
may be related to the genetic makeup of
these people each person metabolizes
drugs differently and the same drug can
have massively different effects these
vary all over the world and are
controlled by genes so one approach to
reducing side-effects is to understand
this genetic variation better so has the
work of Oliver Smithies influence the
work that you're doing definitely
because there has been doing a lot of
work in genetics and completely changing
the field and so that's really important
for us when we are exploring variability
in genetics Oliver Smithies won his
Nobel Prize in 2007 for a way of
altering animal genomes a technique
crucial to genetic research with his
wealth of experience does he think we'll
ever get rid of side effects what do you
think I think the answer is no because
the more wide acting the drug is the
less specific it is because it affects
so many systems and as you narrower
drugs application down its sanctions are
more restricted but then it's often
fooled by biology you might say because
very frequently there's a related genes
which will start to turn on when the
other one turns off it's a very
complicated and become because of
biology and the center evolution has
selected so that we that we're
relatively insensitive to changes in
things because something else will make
up for it Oliver Smithies shared his
prize with Martin Evans who's
particularly known for his work with
mice he was also at lyndale and he
looked at the problem in a very
different way I don't think that drugs
have
defects okay I think drugs actually have
effects and yeah the developers the
pharmaceutical companies indeed the
clinicians are going to be concentrating
on whether this drug can have a suitable
effect and then they try and ignore all
the other effects and say there's a side
effects side effect is our
interpretation of what we didn't want to
happen
a bit like weeds in the garden they're
just ants and unwanted places exactly
yes
actually drugs very largely are
selectively poisons even if they only
poison the function of one enzymes they
that is likely to have multiple effects
and we know that from all these studies
that have been so frustrating of
knocking out genes in mice their what
we're doing is taking away one specific
function it's almost to say you had a
perfect drug that kills one enzyme and
we think all of us you know this will
have a very clear effect sometimes it
does but the real the most cases there
are lots of effects suppose we say there
were ten genes that matter and that the
beach of these genes has a certain
amount of variation in different
individuals then there's an enormous
combination of these tens it's difficult
to sort it out but in the mouse you see
you can control it because you control
the background so no other genes are
varying whereas in the human situation
other genes are marrying so this is a
very good example of this that people
have studying large population and
looking at people with high blood
pressure I'm finding out what genetic
regions are associated with the increase
in blood pressure the results is quite
surprising that genes which you can show
in the mouse have a very marked effect
on Bobby
are not detected by these studies in
humans and it turns out that in in a
human study because of the per se
between this gene and blood pressure
there are four or five intermediate
steps that in the in human when when
this gene varies there's so much noise
of variation here that you don't see the
effect there but now you take a mouse
where all the genes are constants except
the one you're interested in then you
alter this gene and then because these
are constant you can see the effect and
that's where some of your work comes in
you look Hertz trying to predict what
those differences might be what those
side effects off target effects might be
so tell us a little bit about how you do
that so one of the things that came out
recently which is very exciting as the
ability to you to make different types
of pluripotent stem cells from various
people and one of the advantages of this
is for example if we want to make
embryonic like SEP cells from your
material we can do that we simply take
your skin cell and grow those embryonic
cells and then make them into all
different types of tissue and then what
we can then do is come in and start
testing drugs against all those
different tissues so one of the most
exciting technologies right now is the
fact that you can take different tissues
that are made from these stem cells I
mentioned and we can actually start to
build different kind of organs on a chip
and then we can connect these organs on
a chip and say all right if we put in a
drug in lung tissue
how will them move and then be affected
in the liver so we're starting to look
at these populations within the body as
well so you're building a miniature lung
in a miniature liver and looking at how
medication for one is affecting the
other right one of the students that I
met this week has been designing organ
models on a chip blood flow and air flow
and they can look at how the drugs
reactant linked up the different organs
yes I mean these sort of approaches are
fantastic and will help but I don't
think there is a silver bullet
everything has to be taken as it happens
and with a risk benefit analysis is that
the answer if this works is that the
answer if this works that's one of the
answers eventually if we get to this
kind of technology we will be able to
test personally everybody however it's
it's a bit of science fiction right now
is it a better approach to say well well
have your genomic information your
genetic information for some of these
genes and we'll know in advance because
we tested it in some populations that's
in fact this work will work for you you
won't have side-effects when you take
this drug so it's not that we can create
drugs which have no side effects but we
can start to choose who's most suited to
which bunch of side effects if you like
exactly
find out which individuals have the side
effects find the genes or genes that are
different in these individuals and then
say now okay we know that this person
here will have side effects and this
person over here won't
so you screen for that particular thing
and once you know the factor you can
design a relatively inexpensive test to
say well don't use this drug in this
person it's not suitable
are they good over here
it's so fascinating to me this work of
building cells in the lab and modeling
systems but as a psychologist it really
strikes me that the way we experience
drugs our reactions to the drugs it
can't really be modelled by building a
liver and a kidney and no there are many
aspects of biology which can't be
modeled in a dish and psychology is a
very good example probably I would say
that some of these can be modeled in
suitable model organisms and of course a
lot of that works going on particularly
neurological function and one of those
model organisms which presumably be in
mice in mice yes
I'm noticing the mice on your tie oh
well these are my golden mice my work
depended on some really nice mice who
actually did the work and transmitted
the gene out if it wasn't for the mice I
wouldn't be here Martin Evans said there
are no side effects but there are of
course unwanted effects people do
sometimes have bad reactions to drugs we
might not be able to totally get rid of
those but innovations like organ on a
chip and delving into our genome should
help us to minimize them
you
we're here in lindau with 37 nobel
prize-winning scientists 600 young
researchers 12 of them sponsored by Mars
and people want to hear all about the
science that Mars has been doing and
well the great thing about coming to
lindau is that we get to spend time with
sciences rock stars you aware that
you're in the presence of greatness and
the more that we can find ways of
engaging some of the finest minds in the
world to helping us solve some of these
grand challenges and then there's got to
be some great stuff in there
one of the things we do is we like to
have a lunch where we basically spend
time with the young scientists that
we've sponsored to come here and tell
them a little bit about the kind of
company that we are the kind of work
that we do and why we passionately
believe that these great scientists
should consider coming to a company like
Mars for a lifetime career in fun
science that will make the world a
better place
best part really is that you get to
actually meet these young scientists who
will look at you in the eye and say this
is the best week of my life
I just sit them at the Nobel laureate
and have a conversation that is a gift
so we have a science breakfast which is
the opportunity for us to host a
discussion around a very meaningful area
of research of healthy aging so we have
Liz Blackburn who won a Nobel Prize in
this field and we put her together with
a group of young scientists in a forum
facilitated by ourselves let's think
about the huge amount of years that
human lives are right so I made a little
scale bar for you on this high-tech
thing here this is a time scale what's
the maximum lifespan over a worm it goes
from here to here right of a fruit fly
from here to here now things get a bit
better okay let's go all the way out to
a mouse alright keep going keep going
okay we've got up to kindergarten we've
got decades and decades of life so the
science breakfasts are always great fun
highly interactive and a really good way
to have meaningful debate in an area of
public interest but also interest to
ourselves we're in middle age here so
maybe somebody's getting some diabetes
now I mean that's the thing it's not
just your lifespan there's perhaps years
of living with chronic disease I think
you get the point
right I'm just constantly struck by how
we have to be thinking in terms of
enormous timescales that these things
are the world is going to be facing an
aging population we're all going to get
older and there's gonna be a lot more of
us who are old how do we deal with that
helping young scientists realize that
they can work with somebody and realize
that these are problems that the world
has to solve and business and science
can do it together I think the private
sector can play a real role because this
sort of research that can be done by a
company that isn't necessarily related
to just the quarterly bottom line is the
kind of research that's complementary to
what governments can find I think Mars
is a good example of that so we got 37
Nobel laureates here and just over 600
young scientists and if we can play our
role in catalyzing some of the magic
happening between those two groups of
people then we go away very happy
you